[Música]
vamos con revista de prensa aquí en
directo américa de france 24 rosa
pressmás de buena mañana del lunes vamos
a iniciar la semana abrimos revista de
prensa entonces con el resultado de la
jornada electoral de ayer domingo aquí
en colombia que destaca el país el
espectador el tiempo y la silla vacía'
rusa buenos días raúl pues así es no
tanto el país como medios colombianos
hoy apartan digamos del puesto más
destacado de la portada pues la cuestión
ucraniana y sitúan ahí pues las
conclusiones de la jornada electoral de
ayer y lo que encontramos en los
distintos medios es un poco lo mismo no
pues esta consolidación d pedroia
candidato oficial de la condicional de
izquierda es pacto histórico de cara a
los presidenciales y el hecho de que las
consultas internas para elegir el
presidenciable no dentro de cada una de
las coaliciones pues restaron
protagonismo a lo que era pues la
jornada también de elecciones
legislativas no pues por un lado del
país señala que petro llama las puertas
de la presidencia de colombia un país en
el que nunca ha gobernado la izquierda
esto es un análisis
es santa eulalia por otro lado como
decíamos el espectador y el tiempo pues
sitúan en el titular más destacado los
nombres de los candidatos no ya pues
desde el pacto histórico del centro
esperanza y de la derecha equipo por
colombia y por último la silla vacía
pues se señala algunas de las
conclusiones pues por un lado no la
decadencia del uribismo entre otras
cosas también el voto de castigo al
actual presidente iván duque y el
fenómeno también francia márquez que a
pesar de no ser pues presidenciable
finalmente pues fue la tercera persona
más votada en estas consultas y vamos a
ver pues qué papel acaba jugando en la
campaña ya del líder del pacto histórico
no degustado pretty así ese rosa y vamos
a analizar precisamente todo lo que
ocurre esto con nuestro segundo invitado
del día pero pasamos ahora así a la
guerra en un plan es que continúa
centrando la atención de toda la prensa
internacional rosa uno de los ángulos
está en conformidad de la parte de la
población rusa con esta guerra iniciada
por el presidente vladimir putin así lo
vemos en el medio ruso nóvaya gazeta y
también en el 'new york times'
efectivamente ahí es que pues como vemos
muchas veces estamos en media en medio
de una batalla por el relato o no y
precisamente pues en nóvaya gazeta que
es un medio independiente y el 'new york
times' también pues da el protagonismo a
la oposición interna dentro de rusia
pues a esta invasión de ucrania sin
embargo hay que destacar raúl que las
últimas informaciones de la centro de
estudios de opinión de rusia destacan
que un 70 por ciento de la población
rusa apoyaría esta operación especial
militar no lanzada por el presidente
vladimir putin aún así hay que destacar
que no sólo en rusia sino en todo el
mundo pues los sondeos de opinión y más
en momentos tan delicados como estos
pues se cogen un poco en pinzas no quien
hace la pregunta que pregunta es y que
espera la gente que puede ser de ella no
que respondan pero como decías en nóvaya
gazeta es muy interesante porque como
decíamos es uno de los medios que más ha
criticado esta censura por parte del
kremlin y dice que hable hubo ayer
acciones contra esta operación especial
en moscú y san petesburgo y señala que
cientos de personas se reunieron contra
él lo que está pasando en ucraniano
otras veces dice pues se reúne
encontrarlo inmencionable y señala que
algunos de los policías que arrestaron a
unas 800 personas pues llegaba llevaban
la zeta en sus cascos esta zeta de apoyo
a las fuerzas rusas y por otro lado el
new york times habla de los opositores
rusos que se han desplazado a turquía a
concretamente a estambul que han huido
del país entre otras cosas enfadados por
lo que consideran una guerra criminal
preocupados por si finalmente son
llamados a unirse a las tropas rusas o
por un eventual cierre de fronteras o
por el hecho de que pues es su vida sus
modos digamos su sustento económico
acabe siendo inviable habla de una clase
media que ha visto cómo de la noche a la
mañana se desvanecía pues su confortable
estilo de vida y que se pues refugia o
se exiliase en turquía así como en
armenia georgia uzbekistán o cat hasta
que más destacado lunes la prensa rusa
rosa pues en medio de esto que
comentábamos no del a
por la retórica el consumo los callas
pravda destaca también que los
ciudadanos de los países occidentales
que han impuesto sanciones contra rusia
también van a ser víctimas de este
conflicto entre otras cosas por lo que
hemos mencionado ya pues por activa y
por pasiva por el aumento de los precios
del gas y el petróleo en europa y
terminamos con otra de las claves de
este conflicto el papel de china según
el monstruo está en los medios estatales
chinos se reproducen en distintos
discursos bélicos de putin efectivamente
en moscú está en crítica esto no que
algunos medios chinos hayan adoptado
completamente el discurso del kremlin
hablar pues de operación especial en
lugar de pues guerra o de invasión sin
embargo también hay que destacar pues
que hoy toda la prensa occidental ha
repetido esta información de washington
post se una en la cual una oficial de la
inteligencia estadounidense habría
afirmado que rusia pide apoyo militar a
china sin aportar tampoco más pruebas
que esta fuente anónima y por otro lado
el 'global times' destaca también raúl
algo que hizo ya cuando se inauguraron
los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en beijing ahora
con motivo con motivo de la clausura de
los paralímpicos dice dos juegos
olímpicos demuestran el poder de la
unidad a un mundo turbulento y para
cerrar raúl que no nos quede esto en el
tintero destacar que a partir de hoy
también e instagram ya queda
definitivamente bloqueado en rusia
después de que se conociera que meta
permite el discurso del odio contra los
rusos en rusia ucrania y otros países
rosa gracias entonces por toda esta
información de revista de prensa del
lunes la mañana con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado el día